I can declare bankruptcy if I need to
I'm $1,000 away doesn't even matter
we're already there a lot of YouTubers
they get their $10 million house they'll
get their Ferraris and fancy clothes and
all this stuff and then at the end of
the day they end up with not that much
and that's happened to a lot of
YouTubers they're so close to just
falling off the deep end they're just
like I don't even care anymore but I try
to let them know just how truly bad it
is what would you say is the number one
thing that's keeping people poor what
the is this why is this here Caleb thank
you so much for having us in your new
studio this place is amazing thank youp
first we have to get to the drama okay
we're racing you to a million
subscribers and this has been the most
tumultuous race of our entire lives
doesn't even know he's racing no we've
been up by tens of thousands you've been
up by tens of thousands and now we're
behind by a thousand subscribers only a,
1,00 to be precise you are 1,200
subscribers ahead of us I've been
checking every single day your stats
against ours and I've calculated when
our break even is is going to be at our
current trajectory in a few days but our
algorithm is slowed down so I think you
might have a bit of a lead here so you
guys watching racing Caleb we need to
beat Caleb so if you want to subscribe
here make sure to subscri also it's uh
it's my birthday next month my birthday
next month my birthday was a couple
months ago tell them to subscribe that's
my birthday is coming up soon too
subscribe for my birthday I'm a
Valentine's baby okay that's special now
after you guys subscribe there's one
other thing I have to bring up okay
Graham is
unreal what happened today it was
unbelievable I was everyone's getting
all hyped because I'm going to I'm going
to Spill the tea spill the drama we get
off this plane we woke up at like 5:
a.m. very tired I got a bum leg okay I
had an incident on a basketball court
you guys can see the image right here
I'm hobbling I'm barely walking Graham
calls an Uber sends us to a parking lot
miles away he missed I was so confused
first Jack I asked Jack to get the Uber
he always gets the Uber and I was like
ja just get the Uber he's like no it's
your turn to get the Uber so I did yeah
sent us to a parking lot miles away so
weird yes it was weird I saw the address
I'm like there's no way your office is
here it was like off of a freeway it
like an overpass he was like all right
you're here and we get there and I'm
like looking there's no way this is it
so I check your text and I see that
we're five miles away we're stranded in
this parking lot in the middle of
nowhere Graham calls us Uber okay we
finally get into the next Uber my leg is
starting to go really bother me but
that's okay um I Soldier it through we
get into the car drive to another
parking lot miles away he mixed up the
numbers again it's the the right Str and
he mixed the second time I thought it
was the Uber and like made a mistake
like the dude must have gotten this
wrong but I looked at your address and
then I typed it in but I went back and
forth between them and somehow in my
mind I read the addresses as the same
even though they were not you know we
could have been filming under a freeway
though maybe I'm doing this on the cheap
yeah saving the money I think it's
honestly I was on like 4 hours of sleep
last night and for whatever reason that
kind of screwed with my mind so now I'm
like double fisting two coffees here
this is the consequence of Me no longer
filming in my house it's having to find
an office space but we've also had like
six guests come here now and only one
has never been able to find it and it's
you guys you guys getting dropped off
here we got dropped off on the wrong
side and we had to walk around to get
here it's very
confusing this guy anyways Caleb thanks
so much for coming back on the show the
first episode everybody loved it and
they all wanted another one and we have
some tea and some drama that we got to
bring up at some point during this
episode I don't even know what it is the
first big piece is you interviewed boie
and that was something completely
unexpected the interview came out for
those unaware Boogie is one of like the
OG YouTubers he's been doing this for
like 15 years has millions of
subscribers and he's broke and so when
this documentary came out on his life
style people were very much criticizing
his lifestyle and they said he he had
narcissism and personality disorders but
you went at it from the perspective of
his personal finances what was what was
it like meeting him he's interesting
behind the scenes well wasn't even
expected to talk about him like do I
want to just like out his entire
existence no probably not but I mean
okay A little why I heard he was talking
trash after the episode he was talking
trash after the episode but the dude is
just so nice and gentle impr person and
you can tell unlike you guys who you're
the same as you are off camera I think
I'm the same off camera as I am on
camera he's not he like he kind of puts
on a show which I think is why a lot of
people find him to be a little more fake
which isn't surprising why an audience
would fall off like that if like the
person you're not watching is genuine on
YouTube YouTube is supposed to be the
place where you're literally just seeing
the person you know so he was very nice
very happy but then you know after after
we recorded the episode and everything
he went he trash talked on his own
podcast it's so funny cuz I did this
Caleb Hammer episode but number one that
guy was such a dumb he thought that I
actually bought a Tesla anybody with a
brain knows they didn't buy a Tesla he's
like trying to find something to nail me
on he's like going through my bank
account and the only thing he can find
in nail me on is like eating out
look at me do I look like somebody who's
saving money on food he trash talk on
Twitter and then a couple times on
Twitter he was like oh this is for the
drama and this is for that it was very
confusing to follow and like me and my
team we were just like
sitting back watching him just do his
own thing and just confused as to why so
what did he say about you I think he
said I was a dick which fair enough it's
fair I can be a little bit of a dick
true yeah Fair though I was actually
pretty gentle to him because one thing
he's really good at yeah he's very good
at the manipul uh manipulation around
therapy talk what is therapy talk
therapy talk in terms of just bouncing
around subjects and making everyone feel
very sympathetic for your situation and
just making it seemed like everything's
excusable in a way he was very good
around just dancing around things and
was and also I mean he lied a lot as
well did he I mean so I didn't catch
anything that Chick-fil-A thing I don't
know if you guys watched the full
episode but he was talking about going
to Chick-fil-A and he spent like $20 he
was like I got to feed two people you or
I got to feed four people or whatever
and that's why I spent $20 there there's
no shame fat shaming anything like that
but you do not stay at his weight if
you're only consuming for a meal one
Chick-fil-A Sandwich you know if you're
splitting that between four people you
don't it's impossible it's like
calorically mathematically impossible so
he was certainly lying a lot about his
uh overall spending and just making
excuses for things and it's hard cuz a
lot of people that come on the show we
see their statements they'll admit to
things where he we see the statements
where like why'd you spend money on this
he's like oh I'm buying it for other
people not consuming it for myself I'm
like okay so what predictions do you
have for Boogie he might be forced to
sell his house which really sucks but
forced to sell his house just to have
enough money to survive he talked about
moving into like a rural environment
after selling his house but then his
health his Healthcare needs require
being close to like good medical
facilities and people and he wouldn't
have that in the place he talked about
moving so I mean the sad likelihood is I
mean the dude's probably not going to be
here in 10 years that's the hard part
financially speaking I mean he's not
going to be able to make it much longer
with the bills he's obligated to pay
just just his mon L health insurance
cost just as monthly health insurance
cost a lot of money how much it's
ridiculous I don't remember it500 a
month yeah it was something like out of
pocket it was immediately like half or
60% of his like $50 $50 a day just in
health insurance and the dude runs on
bumps too he runs on bumps in like his
little YouTube algorithm so he goes out
and chases something and he probably
used my show for that as well just like
the podcast he chased that he got he
gets a little bump in his YouTube
absolutely but I mean the revenue wasn't
that much more impactful he he was
celebrating bringing in like a few
thousand which I mean that's exciting to
bring in a few thousands but from where
he was and what he needs to survive it
wasn't that much I feel bad cuz I'm not
actually like I don't like to trash talk
people but uh since we're here but yeah
the dude is not gonna make it my takea
away from your episode when you really
did the budget and you broke it down how
much he was spending how much he needs
to spend he was really only $1,500 a
month off at the end of it Assuming he's
going to like cut back where he needs to
everything yeah only $1,500 I mean
there's no reason why he couldn't find a
way on YouTube especially to make an
extra $1,500 a month and he has a lowow
podcast as well that I think is starting
to do okay with keemstar and some other
person that's kind of fallen off the
YouTube world so I mean there's
definitely ways he puts low effort into
things like his patreon and other things
that he tries to sell his audience he
does doesn't put any value into them so
he doesn't really receive any rewards
from them his patreon that came in what
was it it was like 40 bucks or something
his twitch was like 150 he doesn't put
effort into things and actually provide
value that people want to consume as a
viewer or pay for could be though he's
not giving that value because he's not
receiving anything first so if it's hard
to put value into something it's like
I'm making $40 a month why would I spend
time on this yeah with $40 a month
versus I could make more YouTube videos
so I'll keep this going and I'll do this
but which is what I recommended all in
on YouTube but I think you said in your
reaction to the video uh he's kind of
stuck on YouTube 10 years ago yeah he
hasn't really evolved with the platform
you got to constantly evolve but with
all this being said very pleasant person
in person it's interesting that there's
a character on screen off screen because
I'm not used to that most people we've
met they're the same people all
throughout most people I've met at least
um so that was a little weird and then
the trash talking afterwards that was
very weird because
like I I don't think I'm that that
intimidating I'm just I'm just over here
just kind of you know chy little boy if
you want want to tell me to off
tell me to off you know I'm good
with that just tell me in person yeah
although you know what before we go into
that we're here in Austin Texas we've
been traveling a lot lately for the
podcast we have some really cool guest
lined up and we're also doing our best
in addition to that to eat a lot
healthier for New Year's I've been on a
new diet lately and I'm trying to build
a little bit more muscle lose a little
bit more fat and a staple of this new
diet on is our sponsor hero it's
actually it's funny you mention that but
every single morning now I have herob
bread with peanut butter and it tastes
so unbelievably good it's better than
the bread that I would buy at the
grocery store and it's a lot healthier
like just take a look at the nutrition
facts so the hero sliced white bread has
Zer grams of net carbs Z grams of sugar
45 calories 5 gram of protein and 11 G
of fiber not to mention my personal
favorite which is the hero tortilla that
has Z gr of net carbs 0 g of sugar 80
calories 7 g of protein and 15 G of
fiber they also just came out with this
brand new recipe using antioxidant-rich
olive oil which is shown to reduce
cholesterol and reduce the risk of heart
disease so join us in our 2024 Mission
by clicking the link Down Below in the
description which is herob breed and
you're able to get 10% off of your first
order when you use the code IC all you
have to do is go to hero. coist with the
code iced and you get 10% off again the
link is down below in the description to
try it out thank you so much and now
let's get back to the episode what is
your advice for him at this point did
you respond to him have you talked to
him since then well I mean I don't
respond to drama I did I did one little
fiery tweet but was like this is too
mean this is too mean I don't did you
delete it I deleted it cuz it was just
too mean like why be mean you know
online like I don't really get the point
uh but you I was just kind of playing
into it and I was having a little fun
but what I recommended to him was really
doubling down on YouTube and figuring
out where to provide value there in
terms of what his viewers want to do he
falls into a cycle though where he just
he starts getting into something like
begging for money or pulling for
sympathy and he was like guys I'm done
I'm done done playing a character I'm
going to be myself very authentic and
then one month later he falls into
something like he just kind of is on
this endless cycle of just falling into
his own traps for some reason have you
talked to him at all since then or no
yeah we've texted a few times again he's
a very pleasant person like like like I
would be happy to meet with him I don't
play Magic the Gathering but if he wants
to teach me I'll learn like he's a
pleasant dude to be around yeah so given
everyone you've had on your channel do
you believe that Anyone Could Make It in
America okay I think anyone definitely
has a shot but certainly some people are
going to come from harder situations I
think a lot of that comes from uh family
situations if you're raised in a single
family household and a place that
there's like you in a middle of a food
desert or there's just Lots lack of jobs
lack of Education it's certainly going
to be harder but anyone can if they some
people are just going to have to put in
extra effort for you know where they're
born where they come from um whatever
their situation anyone can but it's
gonna be harder for some people and it
might take longer as well might take
longer you take every single person
that's ever been on your show there is
still plenty of opportunity for them to
be able to make it every single person
that's come on my show I see a path for
them to do it sometimes it requires I
mean it always requires a slightly
different sacrifice whether it's cutting
down or needing to go make money more
money changing Behavior getting mental
health help you know it's always
something different but anyone that's
ever been on my show can certainly get
out of it we see a path how often do you
see a correlation between mental health
and financial insecurity oh it's
certainly a lot we it's interesting
because some people have complained that
it's become more of a mental health show
uh and of course we allow the guests to
bring up what they want to bring up um
what I don't like are people using it as
an excuse when it comes to finances
which I'm starting to see sympathy play
in some of the guests trying to do that
so what I try to do as not a mental
health expert I'm not I try to steer
them towards okay this is a financial
conversation sir we can have sympathy
and understand the basis of where things
are coming from if there is trauma in
the past but you need to talk to a
mental health expert who can actually
help you on this and let's talk about
finances so I try to rope people back
into the main line of the conversation
that we're trying to be on but certainly
it's a big play it would be fantastic if
you could have a licensed therapist as
well on the show yeah get Dr K to call
in that would be amazing incredible one
thing we actually want to do this is
just more of a service behind the scenes
because our show is nothing without our
guests um I would love to at some
point if we can afford it have a
therapist that I can have the guests see
if they want to see with no fee and also
a financial adviser that a guest could
see with no fee for like you know a year
or something like that that would be
that's something I really want to do I
want to invest more in the guest post
show uh so yes I mean there could be
more content having someone on send them
to the ranch
like the doctor bille yeah uh but yeah a
lot of them do a lot of them this is
things stem from trauma I think you
navigate that conversation very well
though it's like it's like your
expertise is in finance and also we had
horos on the podcast and he say a lot of
people they come up with excuses for why
they can't do a certain thing but the
only appropriate response to that is
like okay and it's like okay you have
this you suffer from this and maybe it
does infect this but like what are you
going to do yeah it becomes a really
hard part of the conversation it's an
immediate barrier that some people have
been throwing up more than normal like
I'll lay out what the issues are I'll
lay out what you can do and they're like
yeah but trauma and I'm like horos
respon do about that horos response is
always all right then you can't do it
silence and they're like well but I
could I could do that and then they
start to backpedal when when they're
confronted and they say I can't do this
because you know when I was five my dog
died and that traumatized me and I can't
do it okay fine you can't do it
yeah yeah all right too bad all right
see you you're screwed that would be an
interesting maybe it's not appropriate
but it would be an interesting you know
to see if it yielded any good results
I'll test it on a couple people we'll
see where it goes I tend to agree with
them because if if they go in with the
mindset I can't do it the dog died
traumatized fine but it's and that's
going to be self-fulfilling well that's
where I wonder why they come on the show
anyway can't help someone that doesn't
want to be helped in why I wonder why
they're here like you know yeah we want
people to come on the show who want help
right so they'll we do we have an
extensive screen process half of our
team are producers Mak sure we get the
right people on the show but there's
always PE you can never Force everything
out of people they can fully frame
themselves to something completely
different through multiple video calls
and po calls then they can come sit here
and they can trauma dump and it's just
like dude I've never went to school for
mental health why are we talking about
this right now this is not me what sort
of traumas are you seeing is it what
what trauma really impacts someone's
like financial literacy is it divor
fincial they up about that it's no it's
not even that man it's uh the cope the
cope is spending more the cope is they
don't care about going into debt the the
cope is the actions around it and it can
stem stem from any trauma that people do
whether it's something sexual in the
past whether it's you know a family
situation the past a death whatever it
is and then the cope around that is
spending and the cope just feels better
to them than actually disciplining and
knowing they can't spend so they don't
spend you probably attract that type who
cope with finances because they watch
your channel it makes sense yeah this
might seem insensitive but I feel like
it's like the question a lot of people
are wondering it's like how many of them
do you think are just using that as kind
of an excuse and allowing that to like
consume them rather than it genuinely
being like a pushing hand on their back
like no you got to go towards these
coping mechanisms dude it's so hard
because I just don't want to assume
right I don't want to assume I feel like
it's just it would be so rude for
someone in my position to just assume
they're trying to make excuses I don't
want to I don't want to invalidate them
Solutions yes right it's like you got to
attack the problem head on it is that's
why I try to Veer them back on that
conversation I allowed people to go on
trauma Dums for a long time for a while
and were really trying to get them back
on the conversations now you know pull
them back in but I don't want to
invalidate their own life experience
like they could be lying but if I call
one person out for being a liar and
they're not then it's just like oh K the
Bigg think lying or do you think that're
maybe they're taking their experiences
and maybe exaggerating maybe but
statistically we've had so many people
talk about I wouldn't be surprised if at
least one person was lying just using it
as an excuse to not look bad on camera
like they thought they were going to
come here and look good the whole way
and then I'm calling out their
and it's worse than they thought it was
like oh yeah but something bad happened
in the so how do you ensure that people
don't lie on your show uh well we have
the hard numbers now again they can lie
up front and say this is every single
dock I sent you every single dock I've
sent you every single dock then I uh get
them to pull up Credit Karma and then
there's something else that's not there
I'm like what the is this why is this
here you didn't send us that that
happened in the episode that you guys
walked in on yeah uh dude didn't send
her one of the checking accounts and
it's just and one of the debts there was
uh $50,000 to student loans mysteriously
out there know yeah forgot about that
one what can I yeah so we bet we vet we
vet and those people are working their
ass off back there and what it's
impossible to know 100% people can
always lie but before we go into that as
you're about to see running a business
could be pretty tough and keeping
everything organized throughout a whole
bunch of accounts and software is could
often be a huge waste of time and energy
but thankfully with today's sponsor net
site all you you have to do is remember
three numbers 37,000 25 and 1 37,000
because that's how many companies have
switched to netw suite and stopped doing
things like typing in data by hand and
searching through scattered information
25 because netw has spent 25 years
helping businesses drive down their
costs and one because netsuite is an
all-in-one solution that allows you to
manage all of your kpis or key
performance indicators with one
efficient system netw week can help
reduce mistakes for manual data entry
and trust me there are always going to
be mistakes and also prevent the busy
work from scaling with your business
trust Jack because he always makes a
whole bunch of mistakes you don't want
to be like Jack you got to get netw site
so that you could avoid the guy that
called three Ubers to get us
here we didn't have to go there netw
Suite could not have helped with that
okay that was be beyond help okay so get
a full picture of your business and help
make better decisions faster so make
sure to download Net's popular kpi
checklist for free right now at nets.com
again that's nets.com
I to get your free kpi checklist it's
completely free at nets.com thank you so
much netw and back to the podcast so
what are some of the biggest success
stories from your podcast or from your
show like how what percentage of people
that come on can you see a measurable
Financial difference in we haven't done
like a study to gather a percentage but
you should that would be really
interesting should uh what we mostly
have focused on in terms of reaching out
to best guest is their experience to
make sure to improve overall experiences
for people coming on the show we don't
have statistics around this but we do
have a private Discord of all guests
posting their wins and fails we get a
lot of wins which is really good now
we've been doing this for a year and a
half and a lot of the solutions to get
out of it even when restricting
themselves down to zero is like three
years so we're seeing a lot of
progress uh seeing a lot of completions
won't really take place until the
channel is like twice as old as it is so
uh but we are in the guest updates
Channel and uh in a newsletter not not
to plug it but in the newsletter uh we
send out like bi-weekly updates from
guest and those have been more
successful updates it's an investment to
get people here we give them money but
sometimes they spend money as well you
know it's it's an investment to get
people here people that are starting to
get on the right train it's often times
not worth a all right come down from
Alaska or whatever like just give us a
written update let's send it out let's
keep people informed of what's going on
from your situation usually like the the
the the sitting here is a all right time
to get your together you know fire
up the butt then just get going
from there and then when they come back
is when they're like completed unless
they need another slap in the face do
you notice any commonalities between the
guests that are very successful and the
guests that just don't follow what you
tell them uh the guests that are very
successful seem to be a bit more quiet
after the show they really kind of put
their heads down and they really just
start grinding things out the GU that
tend to be less successful we hear from
a little more like they want to be
involved in the conversations a little
more which I'm I'm down to definitely
help them be a part of it but Joseph
who's been on the show four times uh who
I still absolutely love as a person you
know I hear from him all the time and I
know he wants to continue to be on the
show we're probably not going to do that
again for a while because he's been on
more than anyone and he hasn't made much
progress uh a ton of progress that he
should have but um usually those
people tend to make less progress why is
Joseph not making progress behavior and
excuses man he has not changed his
overall Behavior he'll do Behavior will
change for two weeks then he just falls
back into old habits and then excuses we
told him to pay off a credit card and
then we'd pay off some other debt uh me
and the money guy um by a certain
date he started to pay off the credit
card and then he opened up another
credit card and got these different
insurances and maxed out the cards so
what was his reasoning for that had
reason I need insurance so I put the
annual I paid for it annually and opened
a new card to pay for it so sorry guys I
kind of made it but I didn't really did
he need the insurance from your
perspective yes cuz I believe it
was car insurance that he didn't have
I'm blinking on it right now A little
but it it was something necessary okay
and what do you think is holding most
people back uh the it's kind of like me
with the diet which is totally fair me
with the gym it's I think just jumping
in jumping into the deep end you know uh
it's intimidating at first changing a
lot of things changing your entire life
lifestyle if you're going out to eat
three times a day which a lot of people
on the show are just completely changing
that so sometimes you know it takes
slower steps to get there uh which is
fine as long as they actually change in
the end but it's a big hurdle that I see
a lot of people that get fired up after
leaving the show but then actually
changing things around their life that
is their actions they actually have to
take on their own without someone
holding their hands and it's very scary
to make a big change when you've been
doing something for half a decade or a
decade yeah do you think you overwhelm
them when they come on the show and
you're giving giving them this whole
financial breakdown that says if you
follow this for 3 years so disciplined
you'll be debt free and you can start
saving like you said it's a big
lifestyle change but for you it might be
with your diet once a week I'm going to
have a personal trainer come here once a
week for one hour that's it and for
maybe some of these people who need to
improve their finances it could be like
Dave Ramsey would say save $1,000 yeah
and come back maybe you're giving them
too much too soon they're not ready to
handle it their mind can't uh comprehend
all of these changes so they don't stick
with it versus here's a little simple
step just do this and then report back I
would say yes if it was just the
conversation the conversation's a big
picture item but then from there you
know we put them through our educational
program we put them through budgeting
reviews we put them through the Discord
we connect them with resources and
answer questions all along the way so if
it was the big picture conversation and
then go off here on your own I would be
more inclined to say yes it for for some
people it might be too much but we do a
lot of pre-show work and a ton of postow
work so just helping them along the
journey uh I think helps combat that
yeah you Grant Cardone we had him on the
podcast a few weeks ago he said that for
people who want to make a lot of money
they should not be liquid they should
have very little money in their bank
account because that means they're all
in they're all invested they have to
make it work then everyone on my show is
Rich because they have zero dollars in
their bank account so you disagree with
it well I don't know I don't know I
don't know where you're going withad I
want to get your I want to get your
thought on that because I from Grant's
perspective there's an element of Truth
when you have nothing left to fall back
on you have to make something work
you're all in you're all invested Dave
Ramsey ,000 burning yeah burning the
ships it's like I got to make this thing
work and because of that I'm going to be
so much more driven because I have no
money in the account and I'm putting
everything I have in what I'm doing I'm
down with that philosophy but nothing
nothing ever in this entire world is one
siiz foot all nothing ever especially
psychology is not going to be one siiz
fits all um so for some people yeah that
might work for some people seeing that
they're just so close to falling off
this we've had them on the show they're
so close to just falling off the deep
end they're just like I don't even care
anymore I don't even care it's just
happening uh I can declare bankruptcy if
I need to I'm a ,000 dollars away
doesn't even matter we're already there
so for some people it's just it's going
to be different for everyone Jack what
did you say about cuz we had a
conversation on the uh the walk from the
airport about exactly that like do
people feel bad about their situ do they
realize so what I notic when I was
watching a lot of your episodes is like
people are in horrible Financial
situations like hundred hundreds of
thousands of dollars in highin debt just
objectively not doing okay yet it seems
like they're just completely apathetic
to it it just doesn't matter to them and
I don't understand how granted I've
never been in a situation like that but
like I still sweat when you know certain
big expenses come come up and stuff like
that but how do these people they they
just seemingly don't care whatsoever I
was in that situation I was I was in
that situation you know a decade 11
years ago I didn't care because of there
was a lack a lack of Education there was
needing to jump in the deep end it would
be such a change that I just wasn't
willing to take and I didn't see the
benefits of it when the benefits really
going to outweigh it I didn't really see
it and I didn't really realize just how
dire it is so that's where I really try
to get across and sometimes it comes
across a little squeaky but I try to let
them know just how truly bad it is I
kind of talk about it in a way where
it's like this is the part of Kitchen
Nightmares where Gordon Ramsay's going
through all the stinky food and he's
vomiting he's like showing you how
up this is and you probably
didn't realize it until right now and
then we try to get down to the core
issues and what it can take to change
things so like why do you think people
are just so apathetic towards it like
you're literally telling them oh you
have over $100,000 in high interest debt
and they're like yeah see I said that
people are just used to it at that point
Point like 100 Grand to them is normal
it it doesn't seem unreasonable CU
they've already experienced it so
they're experiencing that's normal and
then to them what's an extra ,000 on top
of that it's like 1% of what I owe it's
not that big of a deal we have people in
their mid-30s you know they've been in
bad de since they're 18 it's just it's
just their life yeah it's it's their
dayto day we had one dude and uh we
filmed a couple days ago and he can't
sleep at night because of his that like
he literally cannot sleep like half the
nights because he's just stressing about
the debt so he's finally starting to
wake up to how bad it is but until he
was educated and realized how bad that
debt was it was just every day for him
just building up more debt doesn't
matter that's what I did the day before
it's just normal it's a part of American
culture so my parents told me I could do
what's crazy is that I read something
about the honic treadmill that said you
adjust whatever situation you're in
within about six months so lottery
winners will feel about normal again 6
months from the time they win same thing
like people who uh you know are maybe in
a a car accident they become disabled
six months later they feel about the
same as they did before becoming
disabled so for people in a lot of debt
you know maybe they sign that that paper
and for six months they feel oh that's a
lot of money how am I going to dig
myself out but after six months you're
about normal and then all of a sudden
that to you is your Baseline it's
interesting because last time we talked
about uh it wasn't a full six months ago
well we talked about me not liking like
Internet Hate and stuff like that no I
don't give a like adjusted to I
don't know it's just every single day
it's just every single day that's like
the you were so worried I remember we
were hanging out with you before and
after the shoe and you were just
refreshing your phone looking at
comments looking at videos and this and
that and we're like like I remember I
was feeling the same way and gram
probably used to feel the same as well
you get used to it you get used to it
yeah and I just realize people don't
just really know what's actually
happening here right here well that's
why it's so hard for people to blow up
online like I would say for your channel
you went from let's say Z to 500,000
subscribers really quickly most people
would have to grind through that for
years so they'll get some comments it'll
grow over time as they get used to it so
by the time they get all these hate
comments it's like oh I've just been
dealing with that the entire time but
for you it's like going from everyone
loves me to all of a sudden out of
500,000 people we have a hundred who
hate you who can't stand you and they
want to make that very well known yeah
so it's a lot to adjust to T is very
evil yeah no I'm used to it now it's
show so I get that no it makes sense
most people that are going through their
debt situation every single day it just
feels normal actually you know what I
was kind of thinking about this AI could
quite possibly be the most important
computer technology out there it's
storming through almost every industry
and billions of dollars are being
invested so buckle up the problem is
that AI needs a bunch of speed and
processing power so how can you get
access to it without cost spiraling out
of control well actually if you're
asking yourself that question it's time
to upgrade to the next generation of the
cloud Oracle Cloud infrastructure or oci
oci is a single platform for your
infrastructure database application
development and and AI needs oci has
four to eight times the bandwidth of
other clouds offers one consistent price
instead of variable Regional pricing and
of course nobody does data better than
Oracle so now you can train your AI
models at twice the speed and at less
than half the cost of other clouds so if
you want to do more and spend less like
uber 8 by8 and data bricks Mosaic take a
free test drive of oci at oracle.com
again that's oracle.com
oracle.com the link is down below in the
descript description enjoy and now let's
get back to the episode what would you
say is the number one thing that's
keeping people poor Behavior you'd say
it's just Behavior well number one man I
don't know how much of that is student
loans car payments people oh yeah what's
keeping people for for people on our
show the guest would probably say my
mental health that's probably what they
would say the people that's on my show
from sitting across from Behavior the
change actually jumping in and starting
to take control and becoming an a
financial adult for the first time in
their life you know a lot of behavior
based things in terms of the number one
debt man we've had people it's been it's
been a recent thing where people
consolidate their debt then they just
build up right back on credit cards so
just trying to finesse the system has
been a big thing that has gotten a lot
of people in trouble you know what's
crazy is I used to be and still am uh
very Pro debt consolidation I think the
services from a mathematical standpoint
make a lot of if you have 30 grand debt
and you're paying 30% in interest
consolidate it uh you know combine all
those credit cards get one company now
that you're paying 15% still high but
now you've consolid you're saving 15%
Dave Ramsey is very against that and
I've always looked that advice and
that's stupid mathematically you're
saving 15% why wouldn't you do that but
he says for the exact reason that you
said because people end up debt
consolidate uh debt consolidating
feeling like I've accomplished something
I've already got it taken care of
but now I could open up another credit
card since I'm technically saving money
it's free so I'm going to get that
credit card but he's wrong and you're
wrong it's not one size fits-all yeah
for the vast majority of people mostly
on the show yeah it's stupid don't do it
you're going to build it up back up but
if you can do it if you're disciplined
if you've proven to yourself that you
will be able to manage it absolutely
save that money I I don't really get the
being pro or anti like you need to be
one or the other like I don't really get
why but how do people know if they're
disciplined enough to do that Pro a
track record proven it if you're if
you're showing that on a credit card
you're only putting gas on it and you're
paying it off every single month if
you're able to prove to yourself that
you've become more financially
disciplined you're budgeting you're
sitting down once a month seeing where
things are going and actually assigning
every single scent of your money to
specific task and you're not spending
money you don't know you're proving to
yourself if over a course of maybe a
quarter let's just say then I think
you're ready to take the next step into
something do you think credit cards are
a net positive or net negative on people
well probably a net negative when it
comes to society but like I don't know
we all finesse it and I would love
everyone to be able to finesse it
there's a lot of things that you can
take advantage of that are great if you
do it right but can be shitty if you
don't so for the vast majority of people
I mean yeah it's them so do you
think I've been having this like
internal debate because I know Graham
and I like generally speaking we
advocate for people to get credit cards
if they're responsible about it but do
you think that it's an irresponsible
thing if you're ad for the usage of
credit cards if overall you see it as a
negative no because in the way that like
Grandma's taught it on the main Channel
you teach it with all the extra steps of
being responsible you you haven't gone
on there and just said go get a credit
card said go get a credit card and
here's how to be responsible with it so
it would be irresponsible if you're like
just walking down the street you're like
hey you yeah you go get a credit card or
just you're a booth at the college
you're like sign up for your first
credit card go spend all the money
pimping out your dorm that's
irresponsible responsible but I I don't
think the way that like we've discussed
it is responsible it's not quite like a
casino where you go in and you're going
to lose like the house is always going
to win I think credit cards on average
prey on people who are probably going to
spend more money than they should but
it's not like a they're always going to
win that's the way I see it pretty much
with every type of Leverage I mean
people can get by it if they do
it wrong and that's just one of the
worst ones you can get because the rates
are just ridiculous and anyone can sign
up for it it's much harder to get than a
mortgage but you can do a more morage
wrong as well yeah let's talk about
Leverage What kind of debt do you have
right now uh mortgage primary residence
uh two of my rental properties have
leveraged the rest of them do not
they're in cash because that's how to
get good deals now Ashley should is paid
off by now talked about that last time
fiture did you pay it off uh it it ended
at six months thing so yeah okay so you
just got rid of it off furniture yeah uh
I think I I 0% finan the NZ we invested
in here
I don't know if I'm saying that right
it's a Nas uh it's just a thing between
my two editors so they can work off the
same system without having to Cloud
transfer or wire things so I'm Zer per
in that which is going to be chill just
like the Ashley it'll be done in six
months like I no reason not to five six
five 6,000 five 6,000 6,000 dude I
wouldn't finesse 0% over five or 6,000 I
was like why not like I mean I have I I
had it is that even worth 10 seconds of
your time is just too long to explain to
be worth it I'm just I'm silly about it
I'm silly about it but it's we're gonna
waste more time talking about this than
you just paying this thing well we've
already wasted more time talking about
it than it took for me to do it so it's
already set up and ready to go it was
like a click like I already knew what I
wanted I just used my uh like it's it's
already ready like my so I have PayPal
credit ready you can zero% Finance
something for six months it's just ready
to go so pay anything yeah pretty much
that's really good those who just accept
it I didn't even know that was an option
yeah that's amazing actually we are not
advocating for this neither would I now
I'm running through my mind like what
can I spend the money on and keep the
money in the account and then get paid
back yeah it could be worth it for like
legitimate business well if we were to
buy a bunch of cameras and stuff like
that which is what I essentially did
business so we should buy cameras we
don't need yeah just for the 0% interest
George cell makes the argument I think
it's backed by data that people are more
comfortable spending more money on
credit cards than they are on debit
cards that's another reason why he
advocates for debit cards which is fine
but that's again another one siiz
fits-all which doesn't make sense I love
George dm with George all the time it's
great love to hang out with you George
someday but one size fits all it just
doesn't work dude I don't spend more
money because it's on a credit card I
spend the exact same probably same with
you but you're right the vast majority
they would here's the thing we don't ban
everything for everyone because of I
like to think I'm spending the same
amount on a credit card but I don't know
if I would spend less on a debit card
because I've not used a debit card for
like well do plus years do an exercise
budget yourself but he's going to lose
out on 2% for a month spending no no the
issue with that is I would consciously
know I'm paying with a debit card and so
for me to overcome like I'm testing
myself I'm on the debit card do I spend
less because I know I'm spending on a
debit card and I'm testing myself well
here I'll talk about my psychology and I
think this might be more applicable to
jenzy and young Millennials as
well me swiping me spending cash it's
like it's money that doesn't even exist
it's money that doesn't even exist what
exists is what's a number on a screen
that's what I think exactly and if I see
a dollar go up on a credit card balance
that traumatically impacts me where if I
go spend a dollar bill it's just it just
flew into The Ether that's what I think
it's not accounted for yeah like anytime
that I find 20 bucks of cash sitting in
like a pant pocket or a jacket pocket
I'm think H free 20 bucks yes exactly
spend it on something it doesn't exist
because I've never accounted for it
before yeah so that's where again I
think for the majority yes AB absolutely
they probably spend more money on a
credit card it prevents me from spending
money cuz I see I open the app and I see
a125 spent getting a taquito or
something I'm freaking out I'm freaking
out why did I just spend that do you pay
off your credit cards throughout the
month like if you see a balance on there
you just automatically go hand I do the
same thing I mean I just find myself
opening them like every other day or
every three days something like that I
was going through it it's it's terrible
for my taxes so I'm going through my
accounts to kind of line up where I'm
drawing from which and some of these and
paying off like seven times a month and
it makes it a a nightmare to go through
and and just say I I took these expenses
on the credit card for business but I've
pulled it from the account in multiple
instances to make sure I'm not like
double counting anything or missing
something it's it's pretty bad but I
like seeing the number uh on mint show
credit cards zero and anytime it ticks
up I for much longer immediately ripped
mint yeah I know uh they're moving to
what credit C man right I haven't I
haven't done that yet everyone online
says to wait and there's a small chance
everyone's revolting because they've
kept pushing back the migration and so
everyone on the Reddit subad is like I'm
not doing it until the very last minute
and hopefully they're just going to keep
it going no I don't think so but I'm
gonna hold out until the very last
minute into it right into it into it
yeah yeah I mean I don't know they're
pretty smart they've been successful I'm
sure they'll just do whatever the
they want yeah if you were to create
your own 10-step program let's say like
I don't like that stuff the Caleb baby
steps I don't like it I hate one size
fits all everything is a different
person you think everything is super
Nuance but like not super Nuance but
everything's going to why can't you just
do something to the broad demographic
out of 10 million people this is going
to work for more than half I just think
for the viewers watching like generally
speaking if they want some actionable
structure that they can follow all right
let's think okay one month emergency
fund one month emergency fun let's start
there cover yourself for a month if
anything goes wrong for your needs or
needs plus wants no no W you
kidding me no we're cutting all the way
down we cutting down one month emergency
fund absolute needs absolute needs no
unless the only time I've ever given a
little bit of wants is if they have a
big gap between their minimum needs and
their uh bringing income but usually
most people it's just like that Gap is
not large enough to justify wants okay
start there uh one month emergency fund
then this is where again it's not it's
it's going to be based on discipline but
either either Avalanche all your debts
that are not in collection are owed to a
person or debt snowball your debt so do
smallest to largest if you need to see
the little successes along the way to
keep you more motivated but if you can
be motivated all throughout save the
extra money in the end by doing the
Avalanche method method then negotiate
collections negotiate collections from
there um which is going to be a
Relentless annoying disgusting process
but to overly simplify let to say you
did that cool and then if you had the
conversation with the people
appropriately at the time then pay your
personal debts back like if you owe your
mom some money
now if in the debt process your mom's
like no I don't feel comfortable with
waiting that long then include them in
the snowball or Avalanche process but I
would hold that towards the end if it
doesn't strain the relationship and if
they give their consent on that from
there I go six-month emergency fund or
12- month if you're uh you're you're
your own business you know if you're
your own business you may as well I I
think it's more comfortable to do a
12-month emergency fund closer to what I
have where the average person 6 months I
wouldn't do 3 months cuz now we live in
a world where a pandemic can exist
randomly M so okay 6 months from there I
usually do the 50 30 20 50% on needs 30%
on wants 20% on savings uh it's going to
be different where you live New York
California your needs are going to be a
little higher because your housing is
going to be a little higher but I would
be trying to hit minimum 20% on a
monthly basis towards investing goals or
saving for a home wherever that is
obviously this is where it becomes again
applicable to a different person if
you're 55 you have no retirement a
larger chunk is going to have to go to
starting to save for retirement versus
if you're 25 and you just got a de out
of debt fully funded emergency fund and
you need to start investing so uh from
there it's kind of just 50 30 20 until
you're retired when you're just living
dream it's fantastic I love that yeah
it's pretty concise yeah this just gonna
you know it depends on your age depends
on where you live depends on how
disciplined you are through your debt
pain Journey so there's there's nuances
here and there So speaking of debt when
do you think college is worth it and
when do you think it's worth it to go
into debt to go to college what do they
say if you if you're starting salaries
going to be double what you borrowed for
school I think that's the general rule
that people have kind of agreed upon in
the financial community that it's worth
it so if you know you're going to make
$660,000 and you can borrow $30,000 to
go to school I think college is college
debt or College college debt okay yeah I
mean you definitely justify with the
degree if we can mathematically say that
you're going to have a good return on
your investment I'd say I mean let's
just break it down simple simple math if
it's going to whatever amount that
you're borrowing for college if with
that degree you're going to make at
least twice the interest on the debt
then sure you can probably justify right
I feel I figure that's a relatively
basic way to go about it yeah what's
crazy is that they did a study recently
zip recruiter they found that only 14%
of jobs posted on there actually
required a degree that's it and now
overall not including just all jobs only
45% require a degree as you know I've
recently hired people I never once asked
for the degree or education or even
previous work I gave them exercises to
complete the best who complet push-ups
or video editing exercises and graphic
creation and you know conversational
skills and just uh overall interviews be
funny if you do physical exercises yeah
I think we'd all lose oh no one would do
well uh
but uh no I just hired the best people
for the job I didn't give a single
about where they as long as they're nice
you know they'd get along they'd fit in
the overall culture that we're trying to
build and they get their job done I'm
want the best of the best now Whoever
has the best degree from the I I'd
almost prefer someone without a degree I
mean a degree wouldn't like turn me off
entirely but someone without a degree I
feel like might be a little better for
the job because it shows that they've
taken alternative path that they're
thinking outside the box they're not
just going with what everyone else is
doing that they're pursuing something on
their own I think that's inval
yeah it's interesting yeah pretty cool I
would never knock but it's fun yeah what
do you say to the
critiques what do you say to the
critiques that you are too harsh on
Guess did the camera see that you did a
double take because you messed up the
first
time I did a double yeah you got to keep
that in Jack I screw up so often on the
podcast and you're like keep I usually
cut those out I usually really that time
all right say what do you think about it
uh that I'm too harsh on the guess yeah
um um I don't know I have the
conversation in the way that I wish
someone had with me a decade ago like
the exact same way everyone gets help in
different ways if you don't think you
would get help from being on the show if
that's going to be something that's too
much for
youat congratulations don't come on the
show we have a broad catalog for you to
investigate before and 99% of the people
who are on the show are fans of the show
so they know exactly what they're
getting into they think it's a process
that's going to help them so they sign
up for it
if some people feel insulted watching it
you're not the ones who signed up for
the show have you ever had someone freak
out on you because you're being quote
unquote harsh or mean to them no there
was that one dude who stood up and
started to walk out uh he just he's
emotionally imbalanced in general and we
did not know that going into it so when
I was pushing him too hard he started to
emotionally not react well and he
started to walk away and I was able to
Loop him back in I didn't know I was
good at this but people have commented
that I'm good at this I'm I know
apparently I know when to let off MH so
as people are kind of pushed to that
point where they're realizing how bad
their situation actually is good at
looping them back in turning it into a
more hopeful message so I didn't know I
was good at that people have told me I'm
good at that so I guess I'll just trust
them I don't think I'm too harsh I mean
people know what they're signing up for
and they know what helps them if it
doesn't help you don't come on the show
and they don't yeah some of your titles
though are a little fun like uh this one
dumb blonde can't get her life together
click on that video read the pin comment
into the mic please before people get
angry about the title she walked in the
room and told us she wanted dumb blonde
can't get her life together to be the
title I love you yeah we don't just do
it on our own we work with our guest and
kind of it's kind of a meme at this
point where we just we try to have
outrageous and funky weird titles and
thumbnails but what are the chances that
she said I want dumb blonde and this one
says dumb stripper blows my mind did she
walk in and say I want you to she didn't
walk in and say it but we talked about
thumbnail and title ideas afterwards
with them so we get everyone's
permission not only do we have a
conversation with them they also read
through paperwork and agree to it
there's a whole extensive process to
make sure everyone feels comfortable and
agrees now when you record six episodes
a week statistically there's going to be
a couple people that might end up end up
you know being more upset than you would
like them to be I wish everyone would
have a great experience but the vast
vast vast vast vast majority have had a
great experence how do you ensure that
they don't feel pressured to say yes to
it because they feel like it's Caleb
Hammer he knows what's best because I
don't have the conversation with them my
producers do before they come on the
show and my producers do uh before they
come even to the set and then all
communication with them after the fact
who the producers because I know there's
a power dynamic between me and other
people now at this point so I try to
make it have with an unintimidating
person someone that they can just relate
to that they've never heard of before
and someone who really has their um uh
Comfort uh at heart I'm not going to
mention her by name because she does not
like being like in the public eye but my
gunness the amount of just nagging I get
in my ear from the desk behind me in our
new office of ideas to just make it
better for the guest every single second
of every day she's actively obsessed
with it which is what I need and what we
all need it's we put so much attention
and Detail in making sure they have the
best experience have you had any moments
on the podcast that you thought were
genuinely heartbreaking or like you felt
a lot of internal sadness yes I'm I
don't know anyone's name I know their
face because I'm just bad with names
barely even know your guys' names not
true but there was this girl who was
taking care of her siblings like there
were her own kids and I remember that
episode right yeah they grew up in a
situation where they didn't get anything
so she wanted to provide a lot but she
couldn't afford it in order to get out
of her debt situation so that absolutely
destroyed me and I'm that's I I help I
paid for her Christmas so that they
could have an actual Christmas something
like that is brutal when it involves
kids even though they're stinky and
sticky I still feel sad when you know
the relationship with their sister or
parental figure is impacted by the
overall situation that breaks me every
time that kills me that uh well they had
a good Christmas and I'm being told that
we're going to have a positive update
with her within a couple months on the
show which I'm very excited about what
was the situation for those who haven't
seen the the episode uh the overall
situation in terms of her and her
relationship with their uh family just
uh a really bad house household from her
parents so she adopted uh whether
legally or just you know just uh
bringing them on her brothers and
treated them like her kids but just like
everyone else on the show she was in
debt she could barely afford to exist
but she wanted to give them the lives
that they deserve and I'm like we got to
cut back so that they can eventually
have the lives that they need to have uh
in terms of not growing up with their
parental figure always being stressed
about money not being able to pay bills
having to move a lot because you can't
afford to stay in the place you're
living in we have to cut back and
sacrifice now which might mean they
don't get the nicest clothes means they
might not get a trip to great with flage
was a big thing they like doing um they
might not get to go out to eat all the
time which was like their escape away
cutting back for the better future that
they'll remember more later in life
because they're younger they're forming
less core memories yeah um but that was
really hard CU they grew up in a really
rough home and she wanted to give them
amazing life and they deserve to have
that amazing life just they got to work
for it and so that's why I wanted to
help her out for Christmas and I'm
excited to see her positive update if
it's positive like I've been informed
how would you say your mindset has
changed from scarcity to abundance as
you've acquired more wealth I've become
more scared of retirement for some
reason more scared of being able to
attain retirement I don't know how I've
made more money than I've ever have in
my life but I'm I feel like retirement
is less likely somehow I for some reason
I don't know if because my retirement
goals have gotten bigger which they have
gotten a little bit bigger uh but I
always felt like working the N9 to5 felt
more secure and that I would eventually
be able to retire you know 59 and a half
something like that if I invest
correctly put enough aside on a monthly
basis but now that I'm like running a
team I have an office all this stuff is
just like oh my gosh everything could
collapse at any moment I got to make
sure I'm prepared and I can take care of
people and so there a lot more anxiety
surrounding that and how has your
relationship with money in and of itself
changed as you've like quotequote got
rich it hasn't really change that much
I'm investing as much as I can which is
what I did before um my fun and crazy
spending you know on hasn't
really increased I'll go to a nicer
restaurant every once in a while and
bring the friends along with me if one
of them can't afford to pay for it I
will cover it because I want to
experience that as a friend group you
know uh but I in my money skills and my
overall Behavior has not changed random
off topic question but we took you to
Sushi yeah last time it was like your
first time having sushi right very scary
and you kind of enjoyed it loved it I've
been back so many times you've been back
have you gone to another sushi
restaurant yes and what what's your over
that makes me so happy to hear oh was so
good love it uh overall experience in
sushi man dude it's is so good yeah you
were nervous I remember as some
background we went to this place and it
was like the nicest sushi place place I
believe in Austin Uchi yeah Uchi and I
went there and just honestly it was one
of the best sushi places that I've been
to in terms of quality the type of fish
that they had the menu and you were
there and you're like I don't eat sushi
I don't eat anything raw nothing and I'm
like just try it I don't want the just
just try it and you know what you did it
you tried it yeah you tried it and and
and what happened I liked it you liked
it I was nervous all night when I was in
bed I was like is this something bad
going to happen makes so happened so
I've I've been back there one more time
and then I've been to a couple other
sushi restaurants as well took my team
out after we finished the budgeting
program that we worked so many hours on
we had a celebration dinner at their
sister restaurant it was really good
it's just fun to explore the different
tastes that are on the menu that day you
know whatever fish they have whatever
the chef wants to prepare so I I wasn't
a fancy restaurant person before that so
those have been my fancier restaurants
where I've spent more money than I would
like to spend has been sushi do you feel
more financially secure today or did you
in the in the beginning a little more in
the beginning because I had a job I
don't know man even though you make more
money now I make more money now but
every time I add an employee for a task
because we're trying to launch other
channels a new channel maybe by the time
this comes out we'll have launched our
new
channel every time I add something like
the lease for this office buying the new
cameras dude it's a gut in my like this
is taken away from me retiring if for
some reason the cameras are holding you
back from retirement I don't know man if
for some reason just like people are
like oh Financial audit I don't like
that show anymore am not g to watch it
I'm like oh okay what do I do now I have
employees I probably pull for my own
money to be able to make sure they exist
first that's yeah there's extra stress
on top of it but I love it I absolutely
love it so how much has it grown in the
last 5 months since we had you on
podcast because you have a completely
different operation than what I've seen
five months ago it it you've expanded
from what I see to be like 10 times yeah
I mean this has become a well oiled
machine Financial audit you know people
are taking care of that and we're able
to expand into more areas focusing on
different passion prodct I want to do
our second channel is purely educational
based then we're going to do a third
channel on many documentaries on things
that I'm interested in we're going to
launch a second podcast in that corner
with just us hanging out and talking me
and the team that we're going to upload
on Saturdays so I'm able to focus on
more of the passion things so that's
really fun do you worry that's going to
split attention though that maybe you're
diverting your attention away from
what's working refuse I refuse to start
anything new until something is well
oiled and just being able to run so Jack
and I were talking about this earlier
and Jack was really trying to reel me in
I told Jack Hey listen sometimes we film
these podcasts where we know it doesn't
quite fit with the current style of our
episodes but the really good episodes
I'm like what if we just posted them on
the clips Channel or we had another
podcast Channel where we have a like we
have a backlog of probably 10 episodes
that are already filmed some of them we
try to fit in and slot in but they're
really good episodes it just might fit
with the style I'm like let's post that
on that channel and then guess what we
could do Jack is just have fun episodes
just have people on where we know it's
not going to fit with our main Channel
but we just throw them on we just do a
podcast Jack said nope we got to do one
thing really really really well and we
want people to look forward to that one
episode every single week and know we're
going to knock it out of the park and
I'm like but we could do both and Jack
is really me and you know what I I see
Jack's point of view and I would tend to
agree with Jack slightly more than I
think posting I think that realistically
we will make more money if we do what
Graham says but I still think that it
kind of dilutes the brand a little bit
and I think there's a component of
overexposure if people are seeing you
like a few times a week rather than just
like one time every single Sunday and on
yeah I think that people can get tired
of you to be honest and also like I
think it's weird like posting certain
ones on the clips channel it's like
everyone knows okay this isn't as good
as of of an episode as something on the
main Channel and I just want people to
know every single Sunday you can get a
banger on the iced coffee hour 9:00 a.m.
Pacific time yeah the big eye opening
thing for me is posting Less on the main
Channel going from three a week to one a
week and that one a week gets more views
than posting three a week unless it's
following someone
around we don't need to start that right
now that's oh gosh man bud you took a
wound and yeah that was just poured so
you know what is so bad is I've not
looked at the analytics on the main
channel in 24 hours purposely because it
put me in such a mood every time I open
it it it ruin my nightless Macy came in
and she's like what's wrong it's nothing
but deep down I knew it was nothing it's
nothing choking back tears literally
it's nothing cuz no one watched the damn
thing oh
no it's hard that's why I like second
channels though if that's if that's a
passion that you want to do that it fits
better on another Channel where they
don't have expectations I'm hoping it's
going to lock down it could it's so bad
man so bad for those who are not aware
I've been on this tear on the main
Channel every video has been like 3 to
600,000 views and I had this one I had
been sitting on since October October
three months I had been like casually
working on this video it's following
around a solar salesperson who's making
$1,000 a day and I spent two full days
with this guy going door to door for two
full days going door to door with this
guy in Las Vegas and I pieced together
this video and I was pretty happy with
it overall I knew it was not going to be
a hit but my gosh it bombed worse than I
expected like my Baseline my my like
Baseline was bad I set the expectation
so low and it underperformed that by
like 50% we didn't even talk about it
before this but this is did you watch
the video I didn't watch it why why
didn't you watch it be honest tell me
why you didn't watch it because you're
probably indicative of most of the
audience okay well this is H this isn't
fair I don't I don't watch your main
channel
so don't you made it worse how' you just
said I wasn't interest watch the ice
coffee hour I watched the ice coffee
hour they very funny conversations I
never watched the main Channel I watched
the Graham Stefan show you watch that
that's what I watched back in the day
God that's what you watch God yeah
that's what I watched
back that those videos that's I never
watched that's the lowest effort content
I I put out
I used the the the millennial monies you
know back in the OG Millennial money
days that's what I watched and then I
transitioned to ice coffee hour and
never watched the main Channel but I am
subscribed to the main Channel and I
opened up YouTube after a long day
yesterday and I got in bed opened up
YouTube and I saw like uploaded eight
hours ago and it was at 20,000 views and
I was like yeah I know I know my boy's
not happy over there in
Vegas sorry sorry the change your topic
I'm sorry it's I've not been looking at
it that's good I no I think that's help
I think it's more healthy I could look
at it accept it and move on yes course
of course that's more healthy but at the
same point it's like you're not feeling
the negative emotions that's still a
that's a step in the right direction the
emotions are there I'm purposely just
like suppressing them down dude you
would not this guy we were on the plane
coming over here and I see Graham he's
like got his phone like right at his hip
and he's doing some calculations on his
phone and I'm like I'm like I literally
asked I was like I was like so uh What
uh money calculations are you doing
right now knows it's a money every time
just like randomly dividing multiplying
like all these things doing percentages
and he's like just like seeing how much
money I would have made if I bought
Bitcoin a while ago I'm like dude I'm
like cuz you know what Bitcoin hit 49k
and I remember when it was at 20 I
thought I remembered it trading at 20
and I thought hm 100 Grand could buy
five Bitcoins even should I do that buy
five of them I was like nah and then I
did the math how much that would be
worth today 250 Grand is it because of
ETF launch is that why it's spiking I
spiked up and it spiked up and then went
back down but it's been it's been
consistently 42 to 46 consistently
lately so and then I'm thinking I missed
out on 150,000 worth of profit and then
I was doing the after tax calculation to
be like 15,000 assuming I sold what
would that be after tax and then Jack
looked over me like but it got me upset
because I did this imaginary calculation
on something that I didn't a therapist
there needs to be a therapist here
because that that's like so not right I
feel like to be doing I feel like
everyone does that do you not go back
and like okay I bought Bitcoin I do that
I I did that when I bought my first
rental property I'm like how I just took
the cash bought Bitcoin instead I be
like to million dollars and I'm like all
right there we go yeah there we go my
day is ruined like I think I asked
Graham like afterwards I was like I was
like how are you feeling now and he
jokingly said like my day is ruined like
but that's the thing it's like I can you
go and you set yourself up for these
certain things that you know you're just
like well let's see how much money I
like actually didn't hypthetically
lost by like how are you well I'm pretty
upset I don't know man like I feel like
I did that a long time ago like back
when I like made my money in Dogecoin I
was thinking like well what if I sold
off earlier what if I sold off now like
buying a house just bu that was the last
time I did it and I'm like well this
isn't really serving me but I know it's
fun it's fun just playing around with
the absolutely one thing that I do
constantly um is I'll I'll pick like the
if I if a video absolutely bombs like
bomb bomb bombs I like take that
calculation as like that's going to be
the peak I ever get like what does
annual look yeah yeah I do the same
thing yeah mostly because now I take
care of people and I like payroll it's
expensive so but you also said I think
we had to talk about this October
November where I was like dude maybe you
want to go down to like once or twice a
week yeah and you said well you know
January are you doing that or do you
think you're going to keep your three a
week man it's hard we have discussions
about it in the team we have so many
people that want to come on that we can
just indefinitely record forever um it's
interesting because I think we can put
out different episodes a lot of people I
I got on Reddit today for the first time
in like two months or something like I I
don't get on Reddit anymore I look at
your subreddit believe it or not I check
it out I I followed the subreddit and I
read like uh overall positive I would
say the biggest critique seem to come
from from the guest choices yes or from
the guest themselves from the guest
themselves yeah they don't like the
guest like certain guests say oh this
person did this this person did it's not
like Caleb did this Caleb it's usually
guest selection or the guest themselves
yeah uh it's has spend bad for my mental
health on there so I just don't go on
there anymore but actually before I go
into the story I was going to say on the
Reddit and it was like it was when I
started to check out of the subreddit we
had this dude that came on and he had
the weirdest voice I've ever heard in my
life it was like it sounded like he was
using a voice changer and that's what it
sounded like in real life a deep voice
huh yeah I texted you about that you did
cuz you thought it was fake too I
thought it was fake and everyone thought
it was fake and I was like guys this
isn't fake what episode is this yeah I
can show you I can find the video who's
that one YouTuber with a really deep
voice you
played or Among Us yeah he has the same
thing as that guy yes he has the same
thing as Corpse husband apparently I
learned after the fact see I think it's
such a unique voice I think it's like it
sounds you pay a lot of money for a
voice like that I would I would like
voice little deeper a little deeper a
little
deeper you were living the
dream every child wants to absolutely
live absolutely I was living the dream
and I really really abused that fact I
was like oh I have extra money I can
spend it I I do not have extra money to
spend at
all the top comment is Batman getting
his audit done so we had what did he say
about his is he uh like is he he tell me
about he was he was responding to
YouTube comments about his disorder it's
very you suffer a lot apparently with
that disorder it's like not a
comfortable thing I think you have
damage in your your vocal cords and your
but the weirdest thing was on that
subreddit people were not only just
commenting people were posting their own
threads like Caleb you don't have to lie
to us we know what's going on you use
the voice changer you don't have to lie
to us your audience and I'm like
terrible for what is happening like I
don't know everything will just turn
into a conspiracy somehow I don't know
if it's a parasocial relationship in
terms of just thinking they know what
it's like behind the scenes but it's so
interesting but your original question
um there a few things we threw out there
going down a fewer couple episodes yeah
so one reason why I like uploading three
it's because we can have a diversity
guests we had someone something posted
on uh Reddit today and it was like the
first thing I responded to in a long
time it was like can we have more normal
episodes please can we have episodes of
people that want to sit down and just
get out of debt then I went through the
last 11 episodes and I posted eight of
them and I was like oh here's uh eight
out of the last 11 episodes they were
just normal people who came on to get
out of debt thumbnails and titles were
ridiculous it's kind of a meme at this
point sure but they they sat down we got
a budget and they went on their way and
there's a little bit of squeakiness uh
but they they rang from like a hammer
Financial score one to four but then I
also told them you probably didn't see
this episode because it has a lower
amount of views because less people
clicked on it less people watched for
longer and it got less views which means
it was not recommend recommended to you
the videos that were more wild that you
watched and thought the whole channel is
like the last three out of 11 you
probably think that's the entire Channel
because people watched it for longer
they voted with their eyeballs they
enjoyed the content and it was
recommended to you and you probably
clicked on it and you thought that's
what the channel was but eight out of
the last 11 were exactly what that
person was asking for on the subreddit
post and I'm like you just didn't see it
that's the thing people don't know what
they want I've learned that so quickly
on YouTube people say oh make a video
about this every was like yeah a great
idea I do no one watches it but you make
the video you think people want to watch
more clickbait videos or the more
negative videos are the more Extreme
videos everyone watches them well that's
why I like having three videos a week is
because I can have someone on who is
just chill and we can have that video
and if it doesn't perform as well that's
okay people are still getting help from
it who are watching it and the person
who came on is still getting help and
then I can have a wild episode that
performs the downside is that because
your episodes are so long people have to
pick and choose what they want to watch
not going to watch every single episode
they're probably going to watch one a
week and so now they have three episodes
and like which one am I going to pick to
watch if it's just one a week everyone
is going to say all right I'm watching
that episode sure so you could I've
noticed My Views double going from three
to one I just feel like we're going to
have less diverse episodes because I
want to upload the episodes with the
least crazy people you do that for a
week and then it just sits there for a
week twice a week okay every I think
every Monday and Thursday that's what
what we were thinking about was Monday
and Thurday thday we're considering it
we're considering it so we have a piece
of criticism for you and we want to know
what you okay do you think that you
listen to your own advice you say you're
not a car person but you consistently
want to like buy a Tesla I mean you've
reached out to gram and I several times
about like I think I want to buy a Tesla
but every single time we visit you
you're like this car is perfectly fine
was it a Jeep or something yeah Jeep
Cherokee perfectly fine Jeep Cherokee
love the car never want to upgrade I'm
not a car person and then over and over
and over you're like yeah but that
Tesla's pretty awesome you bought a
house yeah impulsively right not
impulsively but it was an emotional
spend kind of I was looking for about
three to four months but once I found
the place I went and visited about six
times and I pulled the trigger so I
think we framed it a little rough last
time but at the time of purchase did you
really think that that was the smartest
financial decision for yourself smart
TST or a smart I don't think it was bad
but it wasn't like the smartest thing
the smartest thing would always be
throwing money in the market it wasn't
bad only because of how well you do it
wasn't bad in proportion to that I think
you would have gotten a a cheaper home
had you waited and I think you would
have been able to rent a better house
for Less I don't think it was bad I mean
it's like you know because you're doing
so well in
proportion it absorbs a lot of the
mistakes like you make a lot of fuckups
and it doesn't matter sure so well in
terms of following my own advice no I
don't because I advise 50 3020 but I
invest instead of 50 about 80% Dave
Ramsey said something where those
percentages become skewed after a
certain amount and he no longer
recommends that because someone making
let's say a million dollars a year and
they're spending 30% on wants I mean
$300,000 a year on wants yeah which I
would never skews Beyond like 400k a
year which I would never do so
technically I don't follow my advice I
would invest 30% I would go spend 30%
which I wouldn't even know what to do
with so technically no I'm investing the
vast vast vast majority but if I went
and bought a Tesla it would be such a
small fraction of My overall spending
because I don't go spend money on fun
really like ever I'm working we'll go
out to eat or see a movie with the
friends like once or twice a week it
wouldn't be the end of the world how do
you think you can improve your finances
okay so let me ask you what does improve
look like CU technically I could have
half the employees just do this show and
invest invest more money sure let's just
say your overall relationship with money
probably the um oh I'm going to sound
like a guest on my show get ready the
mental health aspect to thinking that
I'm just going to die in poverty at all
times I think I'm just I think I'm just
gonna retire with nothing you still feel
that way yeah yeah and every time I
expand the business slightly I'm like oh
this is preventing me from retiring I
wonder if there's always going to be
something because I feel the same way
and there's always been something that
is prevented me from feeling secure it's
because we know the statistics that
YouTubers on average three years like
you said five years you said is good not
everyone gets to be like the YouTubers
who have retired recently 10 years yeah
so good for them by the way yeah Graham
do you think I'm going to die in poverty
no but you have a significant amount
more money than I have right and
probably access better access to higher
paying jobs than I have yeah and for
some reason you think I'm not going to
die in poverty no and you think you will
yeah can you explain that not on camera
but you probably know oh well now I want
to hear can can you explain it kale do
you think I'm gonna die in poverty oh I
don't think you're gonna die in poverty
right but you have more money than I
have by significant do yeah probably
yeah and then also you have you don't
more money than this guy well you've
just been doing it for so long you have
access to to higher paying jobs probably
why do YouTube channel end though do
they end in like a stupid Scandal that
are just
with that I wonder if if it's easier for
that person to then go make money you I
don't think I hate this this is going to
sound so Cy you are not known
enough where it would impact your job
career out that's what I that's what I
told Jack earlier today we literally had
this
exact cuz it sounds bad to say I wanted
to no no no it I wanted to extrapolate
on that even further yeah
but it's sounds bad to say you sound I
Fair let's cut to the the Chas right
here I I think that's a fair point but
at the same time like I don't think that
your level of like being famous is is
working against you in that case no but
when YouTube channels end like let just
I make one stupid tweet let's say I get
I I don't drink but let's just say I get
randomly drunk you guys COA me into
getting just wild tonight on Sixth
Street and I make the dumbest tweet
that's ever existed in the world just
for some reason and it's just like oh
Scandal planet YouTube drama W drama
alert Philip the Franco show let's go uh
you know YouTube career ends and it's
just like they search for me and it's
just like oh Caleb made this terrible
tweet we can't hire him rip me but you
still don't think that the skills that
you've acquired along the way you can
still work behind the scenes No probably
could could do like an agency yeah
here's the thing you could always work
you could always work MH but I think
that future income is never guaranteed
but you always have what it takes to be
able to work as long as you're
physically able to yeah I suppose what
gives me a lot of confidence is like
sure I don't have anywhere near enough
money right now to retire but I do know
if everything were to crash and burn
right now that I do have marketable
skills that I'd be able to bring into
any other position and be able to
provide value and make money yeah I just
think you could get hired easier because
I just think when YouTube channels end
either they're Peter off for a decade or
they just get YouTube drama cancelled
because everyone's looking for drama I
don't think that all of your influence
evaporates that I don't think that you
get like you know let's just say 85 90%
of your audience turns on you you still
have 10% of 900 90,000 but then you see
people like Boogie I hate to use him as
an example but like he's someone who had
millions of subscribers now he is might
be an extreme but you know he can turn
it around there are certain things that
are he can't get back to where he was I
mean that but there are certain things
that he is suffering from that are
preventing him from getting where he
needs to be that you weren't necessarily
and those I feel like are the really
only things that you can bar from this
that's a good point that's fair
maybe it's kind of when you look in the
mirror and you think you look uglier
than you actually do like I can see you
being successful but I have a hard time
seeing me be successful after you do
like I don't know maybe this is some
projection of some kind what's been the
thing for me that I've noticed like when
I went from the duplex and I bought the
first like real house in La I remember
thinking I'm locked into working just as
hard if not harder on YouTube for
another year to be able to make enough
to be able to sustain these payments if
everything were to go to zero so my
motivation for that year was here's my
payment this is all new earn enough and
then you know do backwards math and be
like okay now I'm I'm financially secure
with this then I ended up moving to
Vegas and then I thought okay now I need
to work another let's say eight months
to make sure that this is sustainable
and then after that it could be another
thing and then you know usually there
there are incremental life changes that
happen and then I'm thinking also like
okay now if I'm okay here I'm okay on
the current lifestyle
but what happens in the event of uh you
know you need medical assistance yeah
okay let's put a padding on that what if
uh kids let's put a padding on that what
if a a kid for whatever reason God
forbid has a has a you know a disability
and that's expensive and you need to
plan for that okay well pad that it's
always like a little more just to like
pad it for these things so that from my
perspective it's always like okay let's
work a little more just to make sure
that situation is Tak care of that's
what this last year was for me before
expanding the business into more
Ventures that I wanted to do is I have
now built my rental portfolio to after
uh Property Management fees after
property taxes after insurance after any
mortgage on the couple that I have and
after 3% for future vacancies and 3% for
future repairs generates $111,000 a
month in cash flow so that was my big
goal for the end of the year and I ended
up hitting that so I mean that more that
more than covers my mortgage and you
know I don't really have many expenses
left on top of that but obviously you
wouldn't want your mortgage to be 50% or
more of your income but either way that
was my Big Goal because if for some
reason things dry up I could live a good
upper middle class middle class upper
middle class life for that indefinitely
that's really fascinating the way that
you guys are explaining it because it's
like a completely different ballpark
than the ball park ad in obviously if
we're just considering finances involved
but like I oddly enough I feel feel rich
even though I am still very far from
like I feel very comfortable growing up
I definitely like I would skimp out I
wouldn't get the avocado on Chipotle in
fact I wouldn't even like go out to eat
ever I would be like uh I'd play what we
call the waiting game you'd go you'd
show up everyone else would order food
and if they didn't finish it you just
eat their food and we call it the
waiting game that's what I did the other
night when we were all out at tacos I
was telling you about this place that we
went to and I checked the table to see
who's not finished with the food and I'm
never gonna say are you done with that
because then people feel guilty it's
like they look at the food and like all
right I'll just give it to you I like it
when they're about to take it away and
say oh do wait can I have it and then
they give it to me because then I know
100% they're going to be done is when
they're taking it you know then I know
they're going to be done with it because
I don't want the guilt food I don't want
them to guilt give me food maybe I have
no shame but I always ask if they're
done with that no so so I saw a buddy uh
Daniel he's Vegas Low Roller on YouTube
and he had one Lobster enchilada and
some street corn that was just sitting
there uneaten and he had he was the only
one with food on the entire table I
didn't want to ask if he's done with the
food and waited 10 minutes they took the
food and then to the server I'm like
wait a second could you put that right
here and I'll finish it and I did it was
delicious absolutely delicious like that
makes sense right you're being
financially somewhat responsible also
you don't want to be wasteful of course
no I think and that's something I really
respect about very resourceful I don't
want to be wasteful that's a smart thing
to do Jack but the thing I don't
understand okay is like the only real
thing that I need to survive is my
mortgage payment which is like 22 $2,300
and I have all of my rooms rented out
and I'm basically cash flow flat like
not positive not negative on my living
expenses and I know for a fact I can
just get a job if I really needed to as
a buser at a Starbucks something like
that and I could still work 20 30 hours
a week and pay for health insurance my
cars paid off etc etc and that right
there is like I'm conf
right it would be hard to ra to raise a
family for sure but I still think that
like that's like worst case scenario and
like that in and of itself like knowing
that that is the Baseline gives me so
much confidence and like I feel like I
feel very secure and also just like the
small little practices of getting
avocado which sounds so simple like
giving AOC getting avocado on like a
sandwich or whatever or not caring when
you're going out to like eat even if
it's like a $10 burrito whatever and
just happily paying for it like that
like those little practices make me feel
like I'm totally fine and well off I
still can't quite understand the the
difference but I know it's a very common
thing well I mean I can't fully answer
the why that's why I said at the
beginning it's probably a mental health
thing like there's probably some
underlying anxiety surrounding it but I
can't pinpoint a why why do I think it's
G to crash and burn why do I think I'm
GNA die on the Walmart
floor I don't know I don't have an
answer do you have an answer why you
think you're GNA no not necessarily my
biggest fear is doing something that I
never want to do like I had that one
experience doing data entry for like six
weeks and it sounds so stupid but I was
so depressed it was the only time in my
life where I actually like would go home
and just feel just miserable I didn't
want to wake up I didn't want to do
anything I was terrible and I never want
to return to that fair enough but it was
waking up every day knowing I got to put
in this 9 to5 I like is this life and I
just saw that for like 60 years doing
that I hated it so badly that I never
want to be forced to do something like
that so the idea of of going into a job
that I hate doing to me is like I'll do
anything to avoid that even if that
means thinking I'm constantly broke and
I just gota like do enough to be you
know to be a bit scarcity but uh that's
where Boogie is right now like refuses
even if YouTube doesn't make money I
think we all think he can make a little
more money on there but he refuses to
get any job any job if it fully stops
he's a YouTuber he has three million
subscribers or
whatever so he thinks I don't know yeah
it's I think it's a humility thing the
embarrassment as well of being Boogie
and you you go into Chipotle for
instance and be like hey are are you
Boogie and servant Chipotle is like oh
can I get a selfie with you and it might
be just but seriously imagine that any
frontf facing job like that anyone is G
they're going to recognize let's take
selfies yeah um I remember we had Devon
work Heiser on the podcast from Ned's
Declassified and like for any kid would
instantly recognize yo that's Ned and he
was working at equinox and didn't care
because he like that was what it took to
support his acting career at the time it
made good money but like he was this
really famous child actor working at
equinox that's what you have to do and
he didn't have an ego it was just like
yeah I'm doing this it pays really well
and I'm doing my acting on the side and
this is just is what it is yeah so I
think I think that's a big hurdle for a
lot of people to overcome bet a lot of
people wouldn't be able to do that just
they would have a pride thing like no
I'm Ned like I'm not going to do that
yeah I probably work at the fish shop
the fish shop I like to go to I love
that everyone there seems to be having a
good time decent manual labor they're
always lifting heavy buckets of water
yeah but that might be good
and yeah it looks fun they're all happy
you know what I thought like if
everything were to go to zero let's just
say I start over with zero today like
and I had to go and get a job uh it
would probably be like a marine aquarium
wholesaler I just go back I would
probably just go back to doing that top
shelf Aquatics would probably be or
worldwide corals one of those two places
you'd help me build my first reef tank
yeah yeah I would or I just do uh I set
up reef tanks for people I think that
would be fun yeah I do that so I I
thought of all of those things I thought
of every scenario if I were just like
all right starting over from scratch
what would I do if it's not YouTube yeah
that's is why I'm investing everything a
lot of people that get into the YouTube
I think we're fortunate enough to be in
the finance space where we at least are
educated on personal finances enough to
know okay at some point this income
might not exist I should invest a lot of
YouTubers they get their YouTuber they
get their um I got a house for $900,000
but a lot of people they'll get their
$10 million house they'll get their
Ferrari they'll get their you know
lavish parties and fancy clothes and all
this stuff and then at the end of the
day it's you know this is kind of they
end up with not that much and that's
happened to a lot of YouTubers what is
it sunny V2 Sunny V3 yeah he follows a
lot of those stories great Channel Lov
Sunny
V3 that's the next stage is there a
sunny V1 does it just gets worse it's
like Sunny B5 at that point yeah so do
you feel like you're conquering your
anxieties or do you feel like they're
still somewhat controlling which
direction you're taking life I'm sure
it's controlling the financial aspect
that we talk about me I haven't been I
haven't visited you guys have been here
three times come to Vegas I want you to
go to Vegas and I want you to see Dave
Ramsey I want to meet the dog I want to
meet Bailey Bailey Ramsey would I feel
like Ramsey would like you oh I'll meet
Ramsey too but I really you see the
aquarium yes yes I would love to go I
think in terms of anxieties holding me
back that's my big one for some reason
I'm just not getting on a well not for
some reason I my Panic is sort of
whatever says I think that's the one
thing I'm not doing yes which probably
good what if it's on a plane with us
listen I'm open to it are you really I'm
open to it hyp hypthetically if we flew
from New York here back to Vegas would
you do that in the next like few days
well no we got a schedule excuses this
needs to be a limiting Bel we have a
schedule to meet if we plan it if we
plan it within like a month that we can
schedule our no no no like within a
specific month that we can take like a
week off you don't need a just two and a
half hours it's a two and a half hour
flight you we we were talking Jack and I
saying how easy the flight was and we
could go here and back in the same day I
did a full video edit on the plane so I
wasted no time the only time I Wast is
just the time it takes to get to the
airport and wait to Bo the plane yeah
the day of Ramsey Show uh or sorry the
Ramsey show come on uh they've stopped
inviting me are you serious well I mean
you just invite sobody so many times
right yeah it's not like it's not like
they're saying I can't come on but
they're just like there was like a
different producer every other week that
was like hey we really want you on hey
we really want you on please come and
I'm like all right so I think feel like
that but that's huge I mean just I I
think that con connection you'd build
what you would learn from him and his
team and just walking in and seeing his
operation I'll challenge his 8% withdraw
on the air good call them out on it D
sequence of return risk but you got to
go there you got to get on the airplane
or road trip zoom zoom I I think this is
less about you physically being there
and more about conquering it is it is
that's my one thing the only probable
benefit is I like being new places I
just don't like getting there so because
I don't fly at least I'm not spending
money on going on vacations no you're
not going to go on vacations but I'm
going to tell you I think it's I think
it's going to be like the sushi thing I
think you're going to go in very
skeptical so much easier and just you
say that but you're sitting you don't
have to consume anything Co I like being
on a roller coaster but standing in line
for two hours I just feel like I'm like
dying like my body feels like it's dying
going through all the checks driving to
the airport getting the parking going
through the lines getting the check all
that leadup there was no leadup to Sushi
you need to do is a first class ticket
you buy a first that much better
domestically yeah okay oh yeah and
you're going to spend under $ thousand
on a first class ticket almost anywhere
in the United States and then to and
from the airport you're going to hire
the best driver you can get a nice SUV
and Escalade that's going to pick you up
take you right there you could even pay
someone to go with you buy an extra $1
thousand ticket and what they're going
to do is just you follow one person
you're also going to get TSA pre-check
ahead of time so that way you skip the
line and you go right in you could make
this so seamless that you have someone
with you at all times sitting right next
to you who leads the way maybe they
could even drive you there you got to do
nothing you could zone out the entire
time and they will be the one that
coordinate everything for two grand
total and it's a tax write off because
you're going to see Ramsey there was an
awkward game of telephone the last time
you guys came down we didn't film
anything but you guys came down to film
with uh Mr Ballin
and um like the I was filming with the
money guy like right before that and
they were like oh you know hey George
we're friends with George just DM George
see if uh they will fly down a plane and
pick you up just kind of as a joke so I
jokingly text George I was like oh it
would be funny we' get this and then you
guys hung out with George the next day
and George must have told you like Caleb
wants a private jet to get here and then
Graham came down he's like I can't
believe you told Dave you need a private
jet to get here that's like just not
even how it happened I mean this just
yeah private jet though that would be
nice does meet Kevin still have a
private jet yeah yeah hey meet Kevin
come meet me and fly me somewhere I
guess I don't know you could ask him you
never know but I I think the big thing
is getting over your fear yeah two grand
get over your fear that's a lot of money
though Gram I'm afraid of flying too
which was never been the case I think I
mentioned this the last time but I
started getting these Tik toks of uh
planes crashing and I watched one of
them and I started getting all the other
ones recommended because I watched one
and it scared me I'd never been afraid
of flying ever but now I I because I've
seen that it's burned into my mind like
plane's crashing I had to explain it
before and it's hard for other people to
understand I'm not afraid of flying it's
the panic disorder of being stuck in a
situation that I can't control and then
all of a sudden I'm far away from my
place my place of comfort and that's
what's kind of hard it's an episode we
probably won't release cuz it was really
short and it just wasn't the it was okay
but we had a dude that was literally
afraid to leave his house like a much
more extreme version of what I had and I
felt so bad for him and the dude took
all his effort to come down from Dallas
and I was so proud of him for doing that
and filming the episode but it's kind of
like that it's if you if you You' ever
heard of those people's experiences look
like that but at a much looser gentle
level so okay you I know it's something
that just needs to be done it's that
overwhelming fear of just actually going
and taking the steps to do it yeah if we
could help in any way let us know you'll
do it eventually yeah cuz I we I would
even go on a plane with you if we like
open up like buying a ticket for me on
the phone you know Google tickets right
now I'll get an anxiety poop in five
minutes like it'll happen like this is I
just get so nervous about it I'd go with
you if you want to go to Ramsey
Solutions I would 100% go with you I
would fly here just to be able to go
with you to Nashville I love it
there it's interesting being live being
live that's nervous easy Dave gives you
a little script beforehand kind of going
over like here's the bullet points of
what we're going to be talking about
it's so easy it's 10 minutes it flies by
it felt like three and they're not out
there like grilling you they're not
going to ask you hard-hitting questions
I mean these are very like novice level
beginner questions that are going to
appeal to a mass audience I'm an
aggressive word fumbler though that's
fine that's that's fine they also have a
I believe it's like a 30- second delay
so just in case like a naughty word
comes out they have a 30C delay where
they can I can't say on National radio
we're going to keep that in well I say
it on the show all the time this is
bleeped I mean I think all swear we F uh
yeah I know I do want to get there I do
want to get there you'll get there
eventually but before we go on to
anything else we have to talk about the
favorite conversational topic that we
had last episode getting back on script
which was dating oh yeah yeah and uh we
I didn't tell Jack any
no we hear that you you have a special
someone now yeah she I think she's going
to stop by at some point um working
right now how did you meet that special
someone fish
shop fish shop yeah she was shopping for
some shrimp I was there looking for some
puffer fish uh she was there with her
sister she was in her scrubs just got
off of work thought she was very
attractive cuz she is very attractive
and I went up to her I was like I like
your classes can I have your
number did you act what did you say it
was something along that line no it was
something you went straight for the
number I was like hey you're really
attractive I was wondering if I can get
your number I like your glasses
something like that it was something
involving glasses it was weird it was
weird cuz I just I I shut down I was
just so nervous like I was confident I
was going up there and then the closer I
got I was oh no then the words started
coming out of my mouth and I was like
what am I doing uh and it worked then we
went on a few dates and it's just been
good it's actually been really nice cuz
some of the hinge dates I've been on
like we would have just normal
conversations then we'd meet up in
person then tell me they're like a fan
of the show and I'm like all right so
you know like 10 times more about me
than I know about you and why didn't you
tell me this before that sucks this
person had no idea that I was a YouTuber
and so still didn't within like a couple
dates I think um so what say you did
when she would ask media that's usually
what I tell people work in video or
media yeah but it was it was cool what
was her response when you asked for her
number she's like oh yeah sure she did
it was a little awkward but she gave me
her number then I think I typed it down
wrong and then confirmed it back to her
and had to change a number had to change
one of the numbers that was fun like I I
went back to her like I started going
away and I went wait was it this and it
was really awkward and then yeah just
texted later that night what was your
first text uh can I have my phone wait
is she like your girlfriend girlfriend
or is she just like you know day
girlfriend in non-name like we're
definitely girl
girlfriend girlfriend boyfriend but uh
she wants like a special date for it to
be official girlfriend boyfriend type
thing I don't know I thought a cute date
would be uh 2424 which is's going to be
gone so we can't become official on that
day so I don't know but yes we are let's
find the first how long ago is this that
you hit on her for lack of for lack of
better uh a week before Thanksgiving
really yeah good for you dude yeah and I
I really respect the uh the confidence
of that she's also made me want to get a
Tesla more cuz she has a Tesla Model 3
then I experienced the self-driving
which is much better than you said it
was last time we talked it's very good
all right listen they they've upgraded
the firmware a little nicer a little
less jerky they trust it a little bit
more yeah have you talked much about her
no she doesn't uh want to be like name
and face and stuff she doesn't really
want that I think you should do a
financial audit imagine we've made jokes
my girlfriend hey I am from the fish
shop my name is Caleb
thank you for giving me your number I
just thought you were incredibly
beautiful so I had to ask smiley face
what's your
name hi I'm blank sorry I was a bit
awkward I was focused on the shrimp
Emoji Emoji exclamation point emoji 100
emoji wait she sent how many emojis
emojis obsessed no she was very flirty I
don't get I don't get emojis anymore
sent anymore you I think Jack a while
ago like the more emojis that are sent
the more into you they are if it's lot
of emojis yeah and that's why Jack was
sending so many emojis and I was like
Dude tell him back no Emojis like one
every now and then five put one got to
note that one of her co-workers and
Friends uh disapproves disapproved when
going on a few dates there she like
showed him a uh showed her a picture of
me she was like what are you doing you
can do so much better but I think it's
gone okay since then but now she found
out you have a YouTube channel and she's
like oh my God she
scored so why was she immediately
interested in you I don't know if she
was um I don't know if she was she gave
you a number I mean you don't do that
unless never had my number asked but
what would I do in that situation would
I panic and just give the number because
like oh what do I
do generous as well yeah yeah but you
know s a few days later maybe
just I don't
know a physical attraction I don't know
maybe just interested in learning about
someone who asked your number it's hard
to say I haven't asked that question
maybe I should ask that question I'm
going to ask that question um but then
we just got along just really similar
interest just we like a lot of the same
things uh we have great conversations
nothing's ever dull or dry which is
really nice um and yeah no it's just
it's a great time anytime I here it's a
great time that's incredible so do you
still have hinge or you're off very
deleted I got in trouble for that one
what do you mean you got in trouble not
in trouble we were in a movie once and
uh like I we weren't official we weren't
exclusive uh we we didn't have the
conversation of exclusivity or anything
yet and a hinge notification popped up
on my uh watch in the movie saying your
most something is updated or something
like that like your most likely
attraction is updated and went from
immediate hand holding to hand went the
other way in the middle of a movie and I
was like I'm in trouble but we didn't
have the conversation did she tell you
anything afterwards or did you just
delete it and uh I learned like the next
day or something that just it just
didn't feel good so then we started
having the conversation of exclusivity
just like you know haven't talked about
it didn't really know have you guys had
any serious arguments not to You Know
Drama bait no no wow no couple
discussions discussions but never an
argument discussion of just like you
know I haven't been in like a long-term
relationship and I a very long while so
it's was just me readjusting to it
making sure
prioritizing some things just things
that she likes in terms of just like
door openings and stuff like that just
feeling appreciated just some of those
more sit down like hey you know I I
would really appreciate this and stuff
like that AR door for her that's just
one thing that she enjoys it's just one
of the Love Languages where she feels
really appreciated service access
service exactly that's a big one uh so
just you know making it known that and
that I was less in the giving access
service because that's not one of the
ways I naturally show I'm more of a
wordss of information person in terms of
what I give and probably quality time no
gift giving I like that as well um you
like to receive gifts or you like to
give give the gifts but in terms of
access service this has been less to
something just naturally that I've
provided so I was like hey I really
appreciate this and this kind of stuff
and makes me feel better and more
appreciated got it and your favorite
things about her her
butt we just get along so freaking well
I feel like that's kind of hard I've
been on so many dates and things click
or they don't click but man getting
along with someone just so just like
that that fit it just feels so nice and
it's just so cool and it's just it just
makes every timer together every time
you're not like oh I got to think of
something to say when we go to dinner
that's not something I have to think
about it's say we just flow so well and
that has to easily does she watch your
videos now no she refuses to why she
says she prefers the gram Stefan main
Channel instead yeah she prefers the
iced coffee hour
uh no she does know who you are okay uh
Graham stay fan I believe great it's a
tough one very difficult all
right I think yeah she watched a couple
your videos when she was back in college
but no she refuses to she's like she
doesn't want to it's still weird for her
when I get recognized she's like oh I
kind of forget you're like this there's
like this other part of just your life
cuz it's just you know me and her and
like me her my friends
and stuff like that it's like that's our
life and there's like this whole other
part that she's just she doesn't want to
be out there she's she's not she doesn't
watch YouTube she doesn't watch YouTube
That's not how her entertainment so I
guess that's one of our differences
she's movies shows that kind of stuff
she does not open up YouTube you said
she was a nurse not nurse she wants
she's going back to school to be a
physical assistant not not a physical
assistant uh physicians assistant
Physicians physicians assistant uh so
she's doing that she's applying in
programs now and she's a some medical
assistant right now could she check out
my foot yeah that's a weird thing to ask
I don't know I feel like you I've been
having probably extremely unqualified to
look at your look at my foot foot it's
just it's very bruised it's you know
it's just it's not I'll be honest we're
not trying to turn this into like a
threepers situation but she can look at
your foot that would be that would be I
just don't know if I need physical
therapy or not that's the main thing
Caleb would you want to watch she looks
at okay all right we're getting off
topic I'm curious uh for you in
relationships do you think that couples
should share finances or do you think
it's better to have separate bank
accounts uh marriage wise I think when
we're
are someone who's never been married I'm
very qualified to talk about this now
what is your because it's just an
opinion at this point no just
statistically we know that uh finances
are the leading cause of divorce so if
we can figure out what our goals are um
whatever best works for that
relationship whether it's we're we're
combined we know where all money is
going we're sitting down we're talking
about it we see every transaction if
that's what works best for that couple
then that's what works best as long as
it doesn't provide that money issue that
is the leading cause of divorce in the
uh in the country if what's best for
them is being separate but coming back
at the end of the month and just
discussing where our finances are and
what we should tweak then okay if that's
what works best for them cool just
avoiding that overall financial disaster
that leads to divorce but I think
think we have seen as far as I
understand that combining finances
typically leads to a better form of
success in terms of meeting overall
goals that we're trying to hit
financially as a couple have you guys
already had that discussion yet the
financial discussion nah but we're
pretty uh I know she's pretty good at
personal finances but too early for that
do you think she cares either way if you
said you want separate finances that
she' disagree with that or do you think
she's just easy going whatever is fine
no she doesn't know how much I make
she's never asked and I've never told
her she doesn't know what I'm worth so I
don't think she really she doesn't
really seem to care about that tell her
right now tell her to the camera tell
her to the camera how much I make yeah
it was a joke it was a joke is it well
it varies on a month-to Monon basis she
doesn't watch the channel so yeah it was
a stupid joke what are your thoughts on
universal basic income Not educated
enough on the subject to have an
informed opinion and it would be
irresponsible to give an opinion on
something I'm not informed enough about
what do you think about giving everyone
$1,000 a month as long as it's not my
$1,000 go for it what if a small portion
of your taxes funded that but you also
received $1,000 a month well if it
statistically in the end proves to be a
better economic system I will go with
whatever the better economic system is
but I would need to see the results what
if you pay in more than you receive
again if it shows better economic
results for the country and everyone
then it works okay if it's proven to do
so yeah do it if it's proven that
our current system is better than that
uh no that's what I would do TR to think
weel every way around getting you to
answer well I don't know I'm not
informed enough about it I don't I I
tend to be in favor of it believe it or
not okay I I tend to think that
Universal basic income would as long as
that could eliminate a lot of the other
wasteful programs out there I think it's
a better idea because from what I've
seen it has to go through so many people
like there's too many cooks in the
kitchen for the government to operate
efficiently so it seems like we have so
much waste so if we could cut out all
the you know a lot of the things that
are just wasting money but give every
everyone, 1500 a month you know that's
what you get 1,500 a month it's up to
you to you could budget however you want
to but everyone gets it whether you make
a billion dollars or nothing Once you
turn 17 years old you get 1,500 bucks a
month okay I think it be quite
interesting to see what happens on that
cool I could be wrong I could be
terribly wrong maybe gr should run for
President we want Andrew Yang on the
podcast this is you haven't had Andrew
no we we have asked we have been asking
for like a year year and a half he's not
doing anything Andrew Yang Andrew please
I have a feeling we're reaching out to
people we're not getting to Andrew Yang
we're getting somewhere up the chain
Andrew's up here and we're getting
halfway through and they're say no and
so we're getting cut off before they
even know we're interested like the
principal that would be Andre Andrew
before the podcast Graham told me he'd
give you $1,000 a month for the rest of
your life if you came on the podcast may
not that much maybe not that much but
Andrew we could work out a deal to get
you on the podcast and Bernie Sanders
and AOC these are three huge guests we
love to have a discussion with what AOC
want to do it I feel like no no she
wouldn't want to do 100% would she would
have nothing to gain too much to lose
for whatever her she wants to do I think
Andrew Yang we just talk about Universal
basic income Bernie Sanders would be
incredible yeah he's basically done with
life may as well do it well that's not
how we're gonna get him on yeah now our
chances went down now yeah all right
Caleb is there anything else we should
talk about while we have you here as
always you guys should have hired me
dicks um and and out a piece of um
let's see Graham what what do I have a
gper about should the minimum wage be
increased oh that's interesting um it's
interesting I mean in Texas the minimum
wage is the federal minimum wage but no
one makes the minimum wage and at least
in the larger
cities unfortunately I I know everyone's
going to hate this answer truly it's not
a topic I've cared enough about to
become informed enough to have a good
answer I don't know cuz I have not cared
enough this is not one of my interest
points that I'm like oh let me study up
the cause and effects of minimum wage
I've heard some arguments for I've heard
some arguments against where do the
facts lie I don't know and I want to be
where the facts lie but I don't know the
facts hey but that's a good answer
though no one should have an opinion no
one should force themselves to have an
opinion based on their ideology what
that's why I refuse to subscribe to an
ideology because then anytime someone
asks for your opinion on something it
has to stem from your ideology has to
stem to the politician you worshiped
that you voted for has to stem for the
political party that you subscribed to I
hate that wherever reality is and
reality changes all the time you're not
wrong if you flip-flop because you know
new information has come out just be
where facts are at the time and if it
changes it's okay to change your mind
it's okay to change your mind I don't
like coming from an ideological place
just wherever the facts are and I might
not be informed like on that one if
there are facts that suggest the minimum
wage should be a certain dollar amount
I will go for that if it suggests that
minimum wage should not exist I will go
for that I don't know what it is here's
a followup to that what do you think
happens when you die I was raised
Christian I've become more spiritual in
general I
TR I TR try to have
faith I struggle with it and I feel like
when I die I rot in the ground but I
want to believe there's something more I
want to believe there's something more
but I struggle with why do why is it you
want to believe something but you don't
wouldn't that be if you want to believe
something you have the power to to
believe it yeah probably but like just I
went through like in high school like a
very rebellious atheist stage like oh my
goodness you know I was raised in the
church how dare I need I need to go the
complete opposite direction now so um
but I mean it's just I don't
know I I was raised that way when you're
raised away from birth you know you
probably just kind of want to believe it
instinctively you know they start
pushing that on to you when you're like
zero this is what I believe forever you
know I was there every Sunday
and but then like all understanding of
just the universe that we have doesn't
suggest anything exist so it's just like
my logic versus what I want to believe
it's it's a big cognitive dissonance so
real answer is uh
it's I don't know I don't know what
happens afterwards but I'm vibing like
let's just have a quick death would you
say you're happier now than you were in
other stages in your life this is say
happier I'm happy wish I could fly but
I'm happy what are like the main things
that are making you happy is the
Financial Security a part of that uh I
mean no no because I feel less secure
now than I ever have but I love running
a team every day I love coming here
Monday through Friday and I love
building something it's so much fun
whether than rather than being another
Cog in the machine it's so much fun and
knowing that it is one of the most
rewarding things on a daily monthly
annual basis getting the emails and
tweets and all whatever of just people
who have changed their lives my goodness
whether it's coming from a selfish point
or selfless point I don't know but
getting knowing that you're actually
helping people and people have literally
changed their lives because of something
you're making is like the most rewarding
thing ever I mean you've probably felt
it it's incredible and it just it brings
so so much joy to my life so I think I'm
happier now than I ever have been
probably when I was an ignorant little
toddler running around and making things
sticky and stinky I was probably
actually H happier but I don't remember
that time so in adulthood I'm the
happiest I've ever been I think awesome
kale thank you so much as a reminder
make sure to subscribe to the iced
coffee hour we're closing in on a
million subscribers my birthday next
month Please Subscribe trying to beat
them thank you until next time cool I
loved it thank you
awesome